- I wanna bring this
up, because a while ago
you gave a commencement speech at Harvard
which is incredibly cool,
and you said something
that was really cool.
- Yeah, many ago.
- So you said, "As you
navigate through the rest
of your life, be open to collaborations.
Other people's ideas are
often better than your own.
Find a group of people who
challenge and inspire you,
spend a lot of time with them
and it will change your life."
I think this is the best advice.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you.
- It is.
People always, I don't even
if they look at you go,
oh my God, your career, you've
done so well, I'm like, yeah,
a team of people like
there's a whole group of us
that have made all of this happen.
Like it's so smart to tell people to do.
- I think you can do
anything with a good team,
- Yeah.
- You can do anything.
And a good team is a team
that everyone feels like
they know what they're working for.
And also there's not a lot
of like, that's not my job.
A good team is a team that works together.
I've been really lucky in my
life to be on many of them.
And I feel like because of that
I've been able to do all
these different things.
If you have a team of people,
and it's could be your family,
your partner, the people you work with
you have people who know you, support you.
care about you can do anything.
And there's no better feeling than like
failing and successing like,
success and failure with someone.
It feels so good to win as a team.
- Yeah.
And it's a lot less lonely
when you when you fail
- When you fail, yeah, and we all do,
that's the thing, I think
that people frown upon it,
but it's like, well
that's the time I think
you learn the most, not
when you win, so yeah,
I think that's all right.
- And I think that
working well with others
is a really valuable skill that
I think is really important.
And I know it's important
with the people I work with.
You like to work with other people.
- That's why your shows, a
lot of that is like your shows
that I love watching, it's
always like, teams and people
like working together make
something happen at the end,
and there's a product and it's fun.
- Yeah, I think that's why
workplace comedies are fun
is 'cause it's a team of people
that would never choose to be together.
(Kelly and Amy laughing)
And you're like, wow, we
have nothing in common.
Let's make this happen.
- And yet we're succeeding.
(Kelly and Amy laughing)